hello everyone I'm sure many of you have
heard of the fooling set technique it is
a very basic very simple technique to
show lower bounds on the length of
communication protocols
in this talk I will show you how this
very basic very Elementary technique is
actually very powerful and it's still
giving us new lower bounds even after so
many years
the specific lower bounds that we will
talk about are lower bounds for gas
channels or noisy cast channels which I
should also call noisy Radio Networks
and the definition is very simple you
have a bunch of wireless devices in the
same room that are communicating with
one another
because these devices are Wireless when
one of them sends a message heads then
the same message adds gets sent to all
the other devices in the room and
because these devices are in the same
room when two of them try to send
messages at the same time then the
signals Collide and none of the messages
go through
so all the parties actually receive a
dummy symbol bot in this case
so one party is speaking the message
goes through two or more parties or zero
parties are speaking everybody receives
bot this is the cash Channel
and what we want to do is we want to see
what is the effect of noise on the crash
Channel
so consider the noisy cache Channel
which is exactly the same except that
every round has correlated noise
stochastic noise in it so if one party
was speaking the right answer would be
the message Edge that is sent but
because of this noise with some small
probability everybody receives a
different message or maybe receives a
bot in this round even though one party
speaking and again if say two parties
are speeding then the right answer is
the dummy symbol bot but because you
have noise maybe somebody receives maybe
all of them receives zero in this round
with some cross and probability so this
is correlated stochastic noise everybody
receives the same symbol but it may be
interact with some small probability
noise can only hurt our channel so if
you have a product or initially that was
taking T rounds now it can only take
longer than T rounds and we want to see
what is the Slowdown that is caused by
such stochastic noise
clearly the best slowdown one can vote
for is constant the best result that we
can show is you take any protocol of
length T and you can run the protocol
even if there is noise at the cost of a
constant factor in the number of frames
so now your protocol is a constant time
state but it does the same thing even in
the presence of noise
the worst thing that you can hope for is
the noise slows it down by a factor of
log n where n is the number of parties
um in the system and this is the worst
thing because what you can do is you can
always repeat each round of the protocol
a lot in times
and then
because the noise is random except with
probability polynomically small and N
the majority bit will be correct
and you can Union bound over all the
parties and all the rounds and
everything is polynomial then so
um login is the worst possible slowdown
we can hope for
transcend is the best possible so down
we can hope for and we want to know what
is the right answer
um for this cache Channel
we already know from prior word that if
the initial protocol is restrictive to
be non-adaptive which means that even
before the protocol starts you know
exactly when each party will transmit
you don't know what they are going to
transmit you don't know the exact bit
but you know exactly which starts that
you want to transmit in
and we know that if you have such a
non-adaptive protocol there is a way to
run it over the noisy cache channel that
loses the non-adaptivity so the new
protocol is adapted but it's only a
constant Factor launder and does the
same job
so if you start with a non-adaptive
protocol you can get a noise resilient
adaptive protocol with only a constant
slow down
and today we are going to talk about the
general case we're going to show that if
your initial protocol is General if it
is adaptive then the Slowdown is
actually the worst possible lot in so we
can go from the best possible to the
worst possible by removing this
prescription
um and this is our main result
again we want to show a protocol that
takes some T rounds over the cash
Channel and has a lot in slowdown or
takes T lot in rounds at least over the
noisycast channel and this shows the
worst possible slowdown between tasks
and noisy tasks and the key Lemma when
we are showing this result is we will
show we will Define the beeping Channel
and we will show that the separation
between the noiseless gas and the
noiseless leaping channel is also login
which is also the worst possible so
there is no noise here it is just the
noiseless task versus the noiseless
steeping channel that I'll Define Nets
we will show a separation between these
two of log n and
it is simple I will not cover it but it
is fairly simple to see why this implies
the separation between gas and noise and
gas so this is the result that we will
show in the start and this is what we
actually get in the paper
and actually this result is much more
General than what it seems you can
actually Define a broad class of
channels it's all the F channels this
class includes for example all the
threshold channels it includes the
parity Channel includes many channels of
Interest it includes the cast Channel
um
and you can show that you can put any F
channel here and all of these F channels
are
beeping is weaker than all of these F
channels you have a protocol for each F
Channel you have a protocol over that F
Channel such that running it on VPN
requires at least a lot in overhead
okay so this Lemma can be generalized
significantly but we shall only work
with this version we want to show the
separation with gas and deep end but
first let us Define the beeping Channel
to define the beeping Channel I want you
to think of it as just the r Shadow
again you have your wireless devices in
a room they all send bits but this time
the channel outputs the or of all the
bits sent if everybody is sending zero
then the r is zero and therefore
everybody will receive zero this is the
one case the other case is when some of
these parties are sending one then the r
becomes one and now everybody receives a
one in this round
the beeping Channel therefore is just
the arson and we want to show a
separation between gas and beeping which
means we want to show a protocol that
takes T rounds again there's no noise
anymore it's all noiseless T rounds over
the cache Channel
such that any equivalent protocol over
the Weeping channel has at least steel
audience
let's do that the protocol we shall use
is actually a protocol for the following
function you have your n players you
divide them into root n groups of root n
players each and you are promised that
each group has either exactly one player
with the input one and the other is a
zero or exactly two players with the
input one and the others are zero and
you have to Output which is the case for
each group so you have to Output root n
Bits one for each group saying whether
that proof has one or two players so
then put one
this is the hard function and note that
this can be solved in root n rounds over
the cash Channel because
in the cache Channel if one player is
transmitted you get the bit if two
players are transmitting you get a bot
and all you have to do is you go Group
by group and each round you have all the
players who have one in that group
transmit if there's only one such player
you'll receive the bit if there are two
then you receive a bot and you will know
which is the case for each group in root
and mouse
okay this is the function there is a
cache protocol for it in root and rounds
and now I want to show that any beeping
protocol for this function has root n
Times login routes at least
as promised the way we shall do it is we
shall use the fooling set technique
which is a very basic technique that I
will now explain in the two-party
communication model there are only two
parties Alice and Bob it's not the
beeping channel it's a simple two-party
model where Alice's inputs are denoted
by ads and Bob's inputs are denoted by Y
and a fooling set for
a problem in this two-party model is
just a set of inputs x i y i index by I
that have the same output so the correct
answer for each of the pairs of inputs
in this set is the same say zero and you
also have the property that for all I
different from I prime whenever you take
two different pairs in the set and you
trust them so you take X from one of the
pairs and Y from a different pair then
there is a cross that you can generate
for any two pairs of inputs such that
the output for this process the correct
output for this process is different
they were all zero to begin with but as
soon as you start crossing your output
is now one
okay
this is what a fooling set is and the
claim is if you have a fooling set of
some size let's say s then
you can conclude that any deterministic
protocol for that function must have
length at least log s and the argument
is the following you show that if you
have a protocol of length of T then it
breaks the set of all inputs into two to
the T rectangles and you show that each
rectangle can only have one element from
the following set let's see why suppose
you have a protocol of some length Alice
sends the first message in the protocol
this message can either be zero or one
and therefore this message partitions
the set of inputs into two parts one top
rectangle here where Alice sends a zero
and one bottom rectangle here where
Alice sends a one
then you have your next round where Bob
is starting again he receives Alice's
message and he either sends a zero or a
one which uh he can use the previous
message to determine which is the case
and again this partitions further your
two rectangles into four rectangles and
this is the rectangle where Alice sent
to zero and now Bob also sends a zero in
response this is zero and then one this
is one and then zero and this is one
comma one so you can keep going you get
that if your protocol of length T then
you will partition this input space into
two to the T rectangles and now
you can argue that each such rectangle
let's say this one can only have one
element from any flooring set it can
only have one pair from any full exact
why
suppose you have this rectangle that has
two pairs suppose it has x one y one and
it has X2 Y2
then because this is a rectangle it also
must have the Prosper X1 Y2 and we know
from the definition of fooling set that
the output for X1 Y2 is different from
the output for X1 y1 and X2 Y2
but the outputs cannot be different if
they are the same rectangle so this is a
torn footage so you get that if you have
a cooling set of size T then you must
have S then you must have at least s
rectangles which means you must have at
least a length of lotus a full instead
of size s implies the length lower bound
of lauders
okay
the only problem is that this technique
does not work for randomized protocols
because a randomized protocol is allowed
to fail on some inputs so it is okay for
X1 Y2 to be in a rectangle if it is one
of the inputs that it fails on and
moreover it does not work for the
beeping Channel it only works for
two-party or similar models and
these are big problems because we want
to use this technique to show a lower
Bound for randomized protocols on the
beeping Channel but let us ignore them
for now we will deal with them later let
us see if our function actually has a
footing set at all or not
the answer is yes so our function is you
have these n players divided into root n
roots of root and players and each group
either has a one or two players with
input one
and the claim is there is a fooling set
of size root n to the root n for this
function
the full set is very simple you take all
the inputs that have only one one in
each room so these brackets here denote
groups and you see that in each of the
routine groups there is only one player
with the input one and this is a
following set because all of these have
the same output which is every group has
one but you take any two of them and you
cross them so that the second input the
red input here comes from this hybrid
and the remaining comes from this hybrid
then but this this set of inputs and the
remaining come from this set of inputs
then in the hybrid you have a group with
two players who have the input one and
this must have a different output so you
have a set of inputs with the same
output such that for any pair you can
trust them and you can get an input for
the different output this is the
definition of fooling set the size of
this cooling set is each group you can
decide where to put the one you have
root 10 groups so it is root end to the
login and if the full instant technique
were to hold
then this would give a lower bound of
lot of this which is root and login
which is what we want
the only problem I did is that this
technique does not hold it only holds
the deterministic protocols and only
those deterministic protocols that are
not on the beacon channel for the for
deterministic beeping protocols it may
not hold
okay
so we need to get around these two
problems for the first one we actually
show that you can generate not just one
but many hybrids from the same pairs of
inputs so here we decided to take our
cross on this route but we could have
done that on any of these groups and we
would have still have an input with a
different output so any two inputs in
our side actually gives rise to many
many bad inputs many bad crosses and
this
the sheer number of these back processes
allow us to go from deterministic to
randomized lower bonds
and the second case the second problem
which is that the technique does not
work for beeping we are able to still
make it work by using the additional
structure that we have in our system in
our system we know that whenever you
take a hybrid you only change the input
of one party and this this locality
where only one of the parties input
actually changes in this hybridization
process allows us to generalize it to
the beeping model I'll not go into the
details but this uses the number of
hybrids and this uses the locality of
each hybrid and with these two things
you're able to show that
the beeping uh protocols for the
function that we talked about must have
length at least root and login even if
they are randomized and this shows a
separation between Cass and beeping of
login it follows that you have a
separation between cast and noisy cast
of login and this is our main result
that cast noise slows down the cast
model by at least a factory flooring so
that's the thought thanks for listening
thank you